hey you hello what's happening
how are you guys doing
hanging in there in beautiful look at
this weather
uh i actually think i can predict what
hotel you're at based on how many times
i've been there it is oh what's it
called um it's downtown it's
uh
yeah um it's on that little side street
getting closer yeah i can't remember the
name but i know exactly where it is it's
right near a chopped i love i love
chopped salad in new york i love chopped
oh is there a chops nearby there must be
there there is it's about three blocks i
know where you guys are
wow
so first of all congrats on everyone's
like chopped what
that got a reaction brought the room to
life i know you really woke us up post
lunch
for people that don't realize it's a
great salad place people are like what
i'm like it's really good thank you for
saying that
listen i i really enjoyed this series
but i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning so for people that have uh not
seen anything that you guys have done
what's the first thing that you want
people to watch
oh wow of our career for our careers
yeah
oh
i would i mean i i
i love private life just because it
holds such a personal
feeling for me
that's a movie i did with paul jamadi
and i i just it's tamara joking and i
just i love that movie
i would say maybe this show i did called
happy endings which i loved doing
with my husband
probably yeah
yeah it's just i like throwing you know
the curveball at the beginning um one
listen this this show is this show is
real good but what's so shocking about
it well for me when i heard about the
show is like no one is actually going to
believe that this could happen how could
this actually happen but as you watch
you realize it's these little micro
moments that all of a sudden
pull you down this path and it could
happen to anyone
anyone can you sort of talk about that
aspect of the series
did you listen to the podcast by the
chance i i didn't that's kind of great
um yeah we had been talking about that
before that it is that's what that
that's why there is such a possibility i
think paul had talked about it last
night that he didn't start out with this
kind of grand idea to take over this
man's life it just happened in these
tiny little
steps like he just had these little tiny
allowances and these waves in to this
man who just happened to be vulnerable
in just the right ways and
you know he talked about how there was a
love between them and that that
friendship just became
some something else it just got a little
bit dirtier and a little bit more
unethical and just a little bit like
uh further and further away boundary
lists from what it had started
did that that's also i think the series
does such a great job that he's really
helping him like this is a legit
solid
i'm helping this man
you know
um for people that i love learning about
the behind the scenes making of shows
and movies what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of the series
well i thought it was interesting we
shot downtown l.a for new york in the
80s and 90s and
studio city for the hamptons
and
yeah i mean we obviously shot during the
pandemic so it was just a kind of
strange experience to have everyone
massed up but i know so many veto people
are dealing with that what else
yeah that definitely i feel like that
would be a huge piece
is to know that so many of those streets
that look and feel so
true and i think the art direction is so
good um
you know that you feel you know i was
uh just feels so authentic and that you
know that was something you kind of
think oh i wonder if they're going to be
able to pull it off and i really was
really beautifully surprised
that people didn't know that we had had
it trotted in new york so that was
really um that was exciting that was a
surprise to me also just like how deep
it got like um
uh
you know it's no joke what happens to
this to this family and this man and
this and this partner and like you know
so it's it got it's a deep it's a much
deeper dive than i think we were maybe
um i'd even anticipated
paul and will like to make people laugh
on set and i'm just curious how many
takes were ruined because of laughter
my god we had a day i was telling you
about it we could not stop laughing the
three of us to the point where we all
had tears running down our faces then we
would reset and michael showalter was
annoyed he was like stop and so that
everyone would come together but no one
could look at each other and then it
just went around robin someone would and
it but it was past the point of like oh
we were breaking it was funny it was
like now we're in the minute 30. now the
crew's like the crew was like please and
it was raining and we were outside
enough of your little antics we've had
it but i don't know something about
looking into paul when he's laughing i
mean it's the last night of course
we had one scene where we're in the
fabric store and he had to say thrive
and flourish to me and i
he just every time he said it i was like
oh brother because it was just get
longer and longer every single time and
it was making himself laugh like that's
the worst is when he he finds it funny
and then we and then it's over
then it's over
um uh catherine i have to um i have to
ask you as a fan of
your work on wand division what is uh
the status of this spin-off that they've
been talking about do you know anything
i
i'm a huge fan of agatha as well as you
know a huge fan of wanavision and as we
all know
marvel keeps it real tight to the vest
so i'm i'm with bated breath as well
we shall see
is it one of these things where they're
in the process of like figuring it out
right now
i can't even know that you're trying to
get it i'm laughing for you i see you
i mean look you know hey my last thing
thank you guys anything is possible
clearly
i spoke to don cheadle recently for
something and before they they were he
even said to me he's like they're
figuring it out now i really can't tell
you anything because i don't know
anything
yeah
yeah you know
my last thing for the two of you um what
was it about this material though that
actually said i really want to do this
i think the actor certainly to get to
work with will and paul sadly i didn't
have any scenes with catherine but also
just this story i mean the fact that
it's it's a true crime but then georgia
pritchett's created this tone of it's
heartbreaking it's really darkly funny
uh
her scripts honestly to me blew me away
yeah me too i had just left i had just
kind of lost a friendship that was meant
the world to me
and it was over circumstances that i had
thought were like about somebody you
know it was a very similar situation not
like exactly but i the stakes were that
high for me and so i could feel myself
in the role of phyllis so deeply
um
and
i also just wanted to work with will on
this level
we had never been able to work like that
i was just going to say i got to go um
congrats on the series for real i wish
you guys nothing but the best and go get
chopped later
bang thank you
cops what if it wasn't challenging again